no mundo não só parece existir face da
aids é fredes num mundo onde existe um
programa aliás vários que decidir
entregar todas as gravações no mundo
também não existe jesus para ajudar é do
vice e de computar as noites para estar
górgia mas existe um homem uma lenda que
parece conseguir pegá lá até lá tu já
sabes que não consigo passar esta noite
eu nem sei quem está falando daquela vez
joga essa [ __ ] seu pulso pronto também
vou já rasgar o ato sexual de quem falou
dar preciso muito bem-vindos é mais um
vídeo e o estrago de que com vocês podem
ver o nosso amigo fight night at
freddy's 4 tem andado evitar um pouco
severo faz nascer 34 porque está lá há
muitos problemas a gravar eu também já
atuou assim karina buhr sido de 6 sua
estada média 80 vocês não sabem quantas
vezes é que fiquei nesta noite e ainda
estou nela ja tentei muitas vezes passar
esta noite não vou conseguir mas vocês
perdem muito mas mesmo muito por isso
hulk fazer o meu último esforço se eu
não conseguir passar esta noite eu não
jogo mais fascinante feliz mas se eu
conseguir pode ser que ainda avança um
pouco mais mas vamos lá pessoal 84 eu
acho que o máximo que conseguir avançar
nesta noite foi até às quatro da manhã
ou até assim que eu não sei eu sei que
estava mesmo possa passar esta noite mas
vamos lá ok eu já provei a experiência é
possível já não sei jogar isto eu vim
porque sei que eu não ia abrir a porta o
imtt tecla mesmo aí meu coração não eu
não aguento já a tua vida que a olharem
ainda meia-noite - como é que vai
aparecer agora a minha noite foi tão
ashika sabe que eu acho que só precisa
ficar ali do escute eu também confesso
que não anda a ler os vossos comentários
para ver as dicas que vocês me deram eu
não andei muito tempo as nossas dicas
por isso tudo aqui completamente sem
saber o que fazer ou não tava num fox eu
acho uma crítica tipo de plástica
eu acho que ela está aqui tá tá aqui
está a minha preocupação agora não é
ética s
obviamente é cama é esta que a macaca
agora parece muito rápido e os mini
fredes e é o bumbum chica internet não
não é esse que tá ali
o que houve é chique aqui graças porque
tac tem que estar atento às formas meus
não estão funciona é esperto não
funciona nem comprar um telefone
eu sou a única pessoa que não consegue
passar esta noite
ai o que não não pode o foco central que
já a meia noite a a assert fox e anda lá
fica lá em blues fox vai lá meu ser
amiguinho das pessoas fosse uma vez na
vida e isso acabou boa noite
não tá aqui ninguém precisa ver a mostra
mexicana na cama ea emel a sério este
movimento tem muito medo
a caixa eo bocal do bush catar que
chique é calma e fecha a porta mas não
querem cair 2 cunha já pode ir embora é
tranquilo daqui é só do estudo
identificaram e que é preciso um fox e
fox já tatuapé rua fica em bush mel
lisboa ataque planejado há quem não
aguentar aqui agora
calma calma calma em um carro ai ai ai
que hoje é é um luxo da canon a sério
como é que eu consegui parar este bolo
não dá é possível esta noite eu nunca
vou conseguir sair desta noite não dá
não dá não dá
deve haver aqui alguma coisa que eu não
vou fazer vai alguma coisa específica
que eu tenho mesmo de cumprir à risca e
eu não vou fazer isso
será que eu tenho que ser mais rápida
ver é ver as portas
não sei nem sempre a cama eo pastel a
usar o rolo está aqui agora risca ela
por si cavalo ea porta de um cine luz
aqui tá aqui o bonin
acharam que tinha caído é boa é boa e
precisa que é um fax da lei não vai
entrar no armário fax daqui
ai meu deus ai meu deus a inauguração no
coração time estava um pouco agora
meu deus meu deus meu deus a minha cueca
taveiro já há ainda meia noite sendo 105
fosse tac a fox e filho da mãe não vai
te embora fox eu não quero aqui foxy na
boa não é só minha inspiração é aqui que
está quietinha tá chegando a prática
está fazendo agora vou ter uma cara uma
da manhã
aí fecha a porta a senhora está aqui
agora é que alguém também faz xixi tudo
ok vamos ver a cara precisa que agora
tem uma muitos bichinhos já o meu deus
meu deus meu deus está aqui alguém faz
se fecha e chove a reedição eu acho que
é do fox mas já está aqui também prontos
a senhora precisa acabar que é pronto
falso de um armário preocupa do pane
boni porque se já não pode enfrentar
logo que não pode faltar em bush
ai ai ai ai que ela já fui já ficou fora
que já está em jogo é que já
ai meu deus justifica por favorecer
chique por favor mas não sou eu sou
muito novo ainda
acho da união na porta
basta alguém na porta alguém aqui é
sério não dá é impossível passar o que
eu vou começar a pensar alto vamos lá a
ver se arranjamos aqui uma estratégia
qualquer a cair vamos ver a porta que o
fox e é boa pra mim ter essa porta agora
sempre a falar sempre a falar porque não
não sou muito burro porque o que eu
tentava em alguém mas vamos acelerar
hoje que a equipa de produção leiteira
preocupa
alguém tá aqui alguém voltar a porta
estava pronto e já foi embora eu taq taq
fox e luxa faça foi isso bom nisso fica
aí a brincar com o teu amigo foxy o o
evento ocorrerá nela
o joel é de acender a luz eu tenho
sempre que um milésimo de segundo a
aheta aqui tá aqui 13 e como é que é
possível uma da manhã
só o tabaco fox e fox estava a filha da
mãe apanha e apanha e apanha agora a
causa precisa ver esta porta e fugiu a
cama
desta forma tem que ir até uma rápida
queda já está cheia moniz uma da manhã e
render nada aqui alguma coisa agora é o
de um pai do agora é igual e até sorriu
o pai do lanche cac milan agora não
havia dúvidas não havia dúvida estranho
mas que ela tava aí toca aí
lá está alguma coisa te ver aqui aqui
alguém amanhã o boni
21 di é tranqüilo tinha porta o que
precisa acabar é um demônio que é boa
o foco está aqui ai não tá aqui chega
também calma
chica chica vai embora é preciso fazer
um lanche na cozinha
ai daquela faixa reclamando esconde 12
ok se daqui a senhora de cama
o fox vai pra cima porque eu acho que a
lei
ai ai ai não apanha de agora qualquer
porta e agora tem que ver o fox e
urgentemente chora por fax
chora por fax aí já não sei os nomes na
lista da canon e sony estão não é
desculpa desculpa por favor desculpa ai
o meu curso três da manhã de ontem tal e
ambiental e alguém aí ainda é boa
qualquer decisão fosse a meu deus eu vou
morrer eu vou e vou morrer ali chegou a
20 km em quatro da manhã e uma criança
faz a porta do meu coração aí meu
coração meu coração eu não aguento eu
sou muito novo eu sou muito não foi
morrer aqui fecha a porta já não sei que
eu vou falar é muita pressão é muita
muita muita muita pressão muita pressão
meu deus ai ai não pela lapela pena não
fecha a porta foi jeito bom nem sabe
quem sabe aqui podem conhecer o
município seja xique xique xique xique
xique a minha amiguinha não faça as
malas conta com a escola do dia de
esticão fuxica do fupis 14 da manhã por
favor
aí aquela que ela tá chegando num 4 4 2
[Música]
ok estamos quase 15 da manhã
ai conseguir subir no crédito mas aí eu
não acredito e eu consegui passar a
quarta noite o vôo editar o vídeo vão
ter ainda hoje que passarem da pouca -
respondeu eu sofri muito muito muito
pelo velho meu deus tô ok
ainda há coisas para jogar vai colocar
em lexington slack que o suposto por
favor tirem me daqui ok já percebi amigo
mas sim eu não sei ficar contigo já
cavou então as pessoas para que vocês
tenham gostado quanto o vosso like
favorito e vamos lá pra no ic5 porque um
deles nessa noite 4 e continuar as
próximas e é o que vou fazer e vamos lá
ver meu a quinta deve estar tão mas tão
lixada mesma série c desta quarta foi
difícil imagina 5ª ea 6ª ea 7ª e 8ª 9ª
10ª 11ª e temos como fiquem bem e até a
próxima
[Música]